today on the matt wall show st louis
university is still seething about the
event that i held there a few weeks ago
and now they've decided to take their
frustrations out on an innocent student
one kid at the school faces possible
expulsion from school for hanging flyers
for my event off campus we'll talk about
that also the media is breathlessly
reporting the fact that various fox news
hosts apparently texted trump
administration officials on january 6th
begging trump to speak out against the
riots that were happening but these text
messages actually undermined their
narrative about january 6th and i'll
explain why an msnbc contributor says
that the texas abortion law will lead to
vigilantes quote hunting down foreigners
how do you make that connection in our
daily cancellation we will deal with the
methodist minister who appeared in drag
on an hbo reality show he's the victim
he says because he was forced to step
down
from his role at the church after the
episode aired all of that and more today
on the matt wall show
[Music]
you know there are some people who like
to live on the wild side and uh they
don't put a protective case on their
smartphones these are these are people i
almost admire the courage that it takes
to do that but you are
you're taking chances you should just it
just takes one careless moment where you
drop it and the phone breaks and you
know going online without expressvpn
it's kind of like that where you're
taking a chance you don't need to take
it it only takes it only takes one
one bad moment to really screw things up
for you every time you connect to an
unencrypted network in cafes hotels
airports etc your online data is not
secured any hacker on the same network
can gain access to and steal your
personal data passwords financial
details etc it doesn't take much
technical knowledge to do this either i
mean just some cheap hardware is needed
a smart 12 year old could do it uh or a
dumb 15 year old could even do it your
data is valuable hackers can make up to
a thousand dollars per person selling
personal info on the dark web that's why
they do this and that's why you need to
use expressvpn they create they create a
secure encrypted tunnel between your
device and the internet hackers are not
able to steal your sensitive data so
secure your online data today by
visiting expressvpn.com welsh that's
e-x-p-r-e-s-s-vpn
walsh and you get an extra three months
free expressvpn.com
walsh
well you may have thought that the uh st
st louis university saga was over now
that my much protested event was uh was
already held and
that's all in the past now
but that doesn't appear to be the case
we are reminded that the administration
officials there uh the ones who run most
of these leftist universities are not
only partisan but also vindictive and
petty
just really bad people
they hold grudges they seek to punish
students who run afoul of them
ideologically and they'll grab hold of
any pretense however superficial or
facile it might be in order to do that
which brings us to slu student james
dowling who faces the possibility of
expulsion from school
for hanging flyers advertising my event
two weeks ago
and it gets even more absurd than that
so this is from the daily signal reports
senior university st louis university is
threatening to expel or suspend a
student for posting flyers advertising
the daily wired mat well daily wires
matt walsh's off-campus speaking event
according to the young americas
foundation the student james dowling was
told in a december 9th video conference
with school administrators that he could
face expulsion for his inappropriate
conduct
and quote failure to comply according to
yaf dowling a member of the st
louis university college republicans
group was putting up flyers advertising
walsh's off-campus event on december 1st
when nearby slu administrators
uncomfortable with the presence of slu's
name on the same flyer as the slu
college republicans told him to take
them take them down according to ef
dowling reportedly offered to cross out
the names on the flyers with a marker
but the administrators wouldn't accept
the compromise
now
the thing to keep in mind here
is that my event was off campus
and the flyers were also off campus so
this is an off-campus event
where the advertising is also happening
off-campus
which means that it's entirely outside
of the jurisdiction of the university
narcs who came to harass james
dowling
there's nothing to do with them outside
of their jurisdiction
they are not police officers
they have no right to tell anyone what
they can or cannot do off campus
especially when the offense is simply
hanging a flyer
and not an offensive flyer either by the
way there was nothing on the flyer there
was no
offensive imagery
just a picture of me which you know
maybe some people would say is offensive
imagery but just a picture of me and
then saying what event it is and that's
it really standard flyer
back to the article it says in a letter
dated december 9th the slu office of
student responsibility and community
standards sent dowling a letter
detailing his alleged breaches of slu's
community standards the letter also
noted that dowling would be required to
attend a hearing for his suspendable
violations
this is not yet another case of
politically motivated prosecution by the
office of uh student responsibility
community standards sou college
republican president nicholas baker said
in a statement shared with daily caller
after dealing with them when they went
after the club for asking another
organization the slu [ __ ] to define the
word woman and learning the the office's
director distributed copies of the
gender-bred person to students a few
years ago i have no confidence in their
ability to be fair and objective in
their
decisions so that's from the daily car
and then yaf over over on yaf's website
they have a little more information on
this so this is what they say listen to
this
during the call with the administration
officials daling was informed that he
was being charged with both failure to
comply and inappropriate conduct
according to the office of student
responsibility community standards
assistant director william bowie
he was allegedly confrontational
disrespectful and failed to comply with
reasonable requests made by the staff in
accordance with their duties
now dowling did uh contact the city to
make sure that where he was hanging the
flower flyers
that it did it was in fact off campus it
was city property and not university
property and turns out that it was
city property not university property so
their real claim against dowling
is that the flyers make mention of st
louis university
now i'm highly skeptical that they have
the authority to tell students that they
can't write the name of the school on a
piece of paper and tape it up somewhere
off campus
i'm skeptical that they have that
authority
but even if they do i mean even if they
can tell you that he offered to cross
out the offending phrase anyway
that wasn't good enough for them
and besides pretending that this was
some kind of violation
and that the student hadn't offered a
reasonable compromise let's pretend that
for a second
expulsion
really
yeah that's the penalty he was
explicitly threatened with
on the call of the administration this
uh william bowie person said to him if
you were if you were to be found
responsible for a policy violation
suspension or expulsion from the
institution are included within the
range of possible outcomes that could be
applied
of course these people can never speak
like real human beings everything is
communicated in uh bureaucratic parlance
but that's beside the point
keep in mind that earlier this year
members of the this slu [ __ ]
organization this group
again that's their name for themselves
it's not my name for them
although as i've said the shoe fits wear
it you know
but members of that group tore down an
approved pro-life display on campus
because they didn't like it
there's a pro-life display that had been
approved it was on campus
and these self-described [ __ ] went over
and tore it down
that's an act of uh that's an actual
crime that's an act of vandalism
nobody involved in that vandalism has
been threatened with expulsion so far as
i know
so this is quite clearly politically
motivated these are power tripping
bullies
still angry that i managed to have such
a well-attended event despite their best
efforts and now they're taking it out on
some random kid who lacks the resources
to fight back and defend himself this is
a classic bully maneuver
by the way the article on yap's site
mentions something that i thought was
was it was a good point
um
whatever happened to the great concern
everyone supposedly has for mental
health and well-being
that's the whole reason that simone
biles was just awarded athlete of the
year right by time or whatever it was
because she's a she's a now a
spokeswoman
a mascot for mental health and mental
health is so important
now this is not the main takeaway here
perhaps but it is worth pointing out
that most of the stuff we hear about
mental health is nonsense
at least the people pretending to care
about it don't
hanging expulsion
over a kid's head because he he put a
flyer up off campus
is you know among other things an
assault on his mental health
imagine what kind of stress and anxiety
that might induce
and top it all off this is apparently
finals week
so you've got that stress on top of it
well as always when these people talk
about mental health they mean it in a
very qualified way they care about the
mental health of their tribe of their
ideological comrades
but a kid who has signaled that that
he's an enemy by associating himself
with me well he can go to hell
we'll just
we'll we'll we'll kick him out of school
let's cause him immense hardship for no
reason at all
and that's why getting expelled from
college is no it's no small thing
that can haunt you for
your whole life potentially
so let's do that just because we can to
punish him for thinking differently
now this is not uh mere bias in my mind
this is evil
and i can tell you one thing
you know i'm not gonna stand for that
slu has already seen what an enormous
pain in the ass i can be
and they don't know the half of it
because i can hold a grudge too and i
can be petty and vindictive too
i think i've demonstrated that
if i've demonstrated anything it's that
so if they move forward with trying to
expel this student they're going to have
many more headaches in the future to
deal with i promise you that
so just leave this kid alone you damned
sociopaths
now let's get to our five headlines
[Music]
it's the holiday season a time for
warmth and cheer and joy
uh if you're into that kind of thing but
you know what it's also time for it's a
time for cyber criminals
to stalk you
and ruin your life
some tips to help you stay safe while
holiday shopping include only visiting
secure sites and apps from retailers you
trust using a vpn instead of public
wi-fi creating strong passwords and
checking your bank and credit accounts
for fraud often every day listen we put
our information at risk on the internet
in an instant especially um
during this time of year when you're
when you're doing a lot of online
shopping everything in an instant a
cyber criminal can steal what's yours
sometimes even harm your finances your
credit your reputation and that's why
it's so good that there's lifelock
lifelock helps detect a wide range of
identity threats uh things that you
might not know about if you don't have
life lifelong like your social security
number being for sale on the dark web if
they detect your information has
potentially been compromised they'll
send you an alert and if god forbid
something does happen you do fall victim
to this you have access to a dedicated
restoration specialist who's going to
help set everything right nobody can
prevent all identities after monitoring
all transactions at all businesses but
you can help protect what's yours with
lifelock by norton join now and save up
to 25 off your first year by going to
lifelock.com wells that's lifelock.com
walsh for 25 off
so as i mentioned yesterday we're in
california and uh man we were we were
driving
through the city yesterday on our way to
film an episode of dr phil and more on
that in a second but um we were on the
way and dear god i mean this city is an
embarrassment it is a
a hell hole
a giant garbage dump
just one enormous collapsing junkyard
trash strewn all over the place
tent cities homeless people
uh boarded up buildings
everywhere you drive it's like this
the whole city
ironically it looks like the apocalypse
and it also makes you pray for one at
the same time
wait i i'm driving through it i'm
thinking how could anyone live in a
place like this
how could you choose to live here
this whole city is one giant pulsating
herpes sore i think about the i think
about that scene remember that if you've
ever seen the revenant with uh leo
dicaprio and there's that one scene
where he's trying to escape the freezing
cold he's out in the forest and he's
freezing to death so he he climbs inside
a hollowed-out uh horse carcass and
sleeps there for the night and i think
that i would i would rather do that i
would rather take up residence inside
the gutted cavity of a rotting horse
than live in l.a
it is just disgusting and dirty and
awful and dangerous
and it's humiliating okay it's
embarrassing that's the other thing i
was thinking as we're driving through
i'm embarrassed
as an american to have something like
this in my country to have to say
that
this is an american city is embarrassing
to me
i mean we're driving through with our
phones out
taking pictures and i'm thinking about
how people have been doing this in la
for decades right like tourists driving
around taking pictures that's what my
wife was doing we visited southern
california about 10 years ago on
vacation and
something that i would never even think
about doing now and that was only 10
years ago but we're driving around and
she's taking pictures and you know in
the past you're taking pictures of
celebrities houses or uh or or you know
you're at the beach you're taking
pictures or you're taking pictures of
famous places from movies or whatever
but but yesterday we were taking
pictures of the biggest hobo camps that
we found
oh there's another one look at that wow
it's the most depressing sightseeing
tour of all time
and then i thought maybe la should just
go with that i mean
try to restart their tourist industry
with this make make lemonade out of
lemons
now come to los angeles and see the
world's largest pile of discarded shoes
i don't know
this is what democrat rule gets you i
mean really they they have
the democrat party has
totally destroyed reduced these cities
to rubble these once great cities the
los angeles used to be
you know something you thought about
when you thought about the american
dream
people coming out to la to make it and
pursue their dreams or whatever now it's
it is
it's thoroughly
depressing and awful and anyway yeah so
i went to we we went on doctor i can't
really talk much about it but um i will
say that what i have been told i can say
is that we were filming an episode
on the issue of uh pronouns
and kind of gender ideology in general
but focusing especially on on pronouns
and preferred pronouns and all the new
pronouns that are out there non-binary
and all this kind of stuff
and um i was uh on the episode on a i
ended up on a panel basically with
um a non-binary
diversity consultant
and his or he would say there
um his uh
trans
partner who's also a
diversity consultant
then we also had a liberal college
professor and then there was also a um
a non-binary parent who's raising their
child genderless and so i was on a panel
with these people on dr phil and all i
can say is uh
you will you will enjoy the episode i
think it's going to be a lot of fun when
it comes out i'll let you know when it
airs the the studio audience i think
that you in this audience you will enjoy
the episode
and i'm hoping that you'll you'll enjoy
my contributions to the conversation uh
the studio audience did not enjoy what i
had to say uh they were they were not
fans i'll just put it to you that way
all right so this is from mediaite it
says during a meeting of the house
select committee investigating the
january 6 capital riot
representative liz chaney read aloud
text messages from fox news hosts and
donald trump jr sent to trump white
house chief of staff mark meadows as the
violence unfolded
cheney read the correspondence just
before the committee voted unanimously
on monday evening to recommend the
department of justice charge
meadows with criminal contempt of
congress for refusing to cooperate with
the committee
and cheney said multiple fox news hosts
knew the president needed to act
immediately they texted mr meadows and
he has turned over those texts
laura ingram texted mark the president
needs to tell people in the capital to
go home this is hurting all of us he's
destroying his legacy
brian kilmeade said please get him on tv
destroying everything you guys have
accomplished
sean hannity texted can he make a
statement ask people to leave the
capitol
trump jr texted he's got to condemn this
[ __ ] asap the capitol police tweet is
not enough
and so the media is making making hay
with this of course um
i'm not exactly sure what they think
this proves
for them
because what they've told us about about
january 6 is that it was a conspiracy to
overthrow the government and it was a
conspiracy to overturn you know
democracy and that it was uh in that
everybody was in on it and fox was in on
it
and laura ingram and sean hannity they
were all in on it and this was all a
plan
right that's why some people were
the this this event was promoted ahead
of time
and uh and you know like anybody who
knew about it they all knew what was
going to happen and they wanted this to
happen and everything else
well these text messages just
prove yet again that that's not the case
that
nobody wanted it nobody on the outside
wanted this wanted it to turn into a
riot they wanted it to stop
they saw it for what it was which was an
incredibly foolish and stupid thing to
do
and utterly and totally self-destructive
obviously
and that's what they saw so how what
does that prove
again if if it proves anything
and i'm not sure i'm not exactly sure
why text messages from fox news hosts
have to be read
in congress
what they're not elected representatives
what who cares what they said
even if laura ingram had texted and said
this is the greatest thing ever i love
it which she wouldn't have done but even
if she had so
what what relevance does that have in
this committee hearing
well it's because it's just a it's a
it's a show trial it's a witch hunt and
so um everything that might be
politically useful to the democrats is
relevant that's the reason and i
understand that so i'm speaking
rhetorically here but
um but that's not what was what anybody
said
so what we have here is more proof that
this is not a conspiracy not pre-planned
this was a a rally a demonstration that
got
wildly out of hand
that's what it was
all right
um
so next we have this of course we know
that the uh the attack and waka show
i mean you may remember that remember
when a you know a blm supporter
rammed his car into a christmas parade
and injured dozens of people and
murdered six people including elderly
people and a child
uh you may you may remember that but the
media has you know within a day they've
moved on from it
but the byte administration is it would
seem finally sort of acknowledging at
least on the surface it seems that way
if you read some of the headlines
because there are people from the white
house that are going to be showing up in
waukesha on wednesday
but then you keep reading and you
discover that well they're only sending
jill biden
the joe biden president is not going
he doesn't care but his wife is going to
go
and then there's more this is from the
hill it says a trio of biden
administration officials will visit
wisconsin on wednesday
to promote coronavirus
vaccines and meet with victims and first
responders of the waukesha parade attack
last month
first lady jill biden second gentleman
doug emhoff and surgeon general vivek
murthy
will all make the trip to milwaukee and
waukesha this week the white house
announced on monday i mean think about
this this is worse than
not visiting this is a lot worse than
not going at all
and saying nothing about it and
pretending like it didn't happen which
is what the administration has been
doing
now you're sending the first lady
and the husband of the vice president
you can't even get the vice president
you're getting her hand-picked husband
and the surgeon general is what does a
surgeon general have to do with this
well it's because the group will meet
with victims of the tragedy at
children's wisconsin
hospital in addition to meeting with
health care workers and children who
just received covet 19 vaccines
biden and emhoff are scheduled to make
brief remarks as part of the white
house's effort
to encourage covet 19 vaccines in those
ages 5 and up
so really
they they feel like politically
someone has to make a brief appearance
in waukesha so they have no point
so they're sending in not even the jv
team i mean they're sending in the
backups of the jeep they're sending in
the the bench riders on the jv team
um which
the husband of the vice president nobody
likes they're setting him and jill biden
in the surgeon general
and really what they're going to be
talking about is getting kids vaccinated
five and up and then they'll they'll
throw in oh yeah i mean this thing in a
walker should happen too and that was
bad
i think what what a mockery this is
a child was killed
in waukesha and they're
sending the surgeon general to wakasha
to talk about why
children should get vaccinated
it's a it's a joke it's a sick joke it's
a very not funny joke that they're
making of this
once again simply evil people okay next
here's claire mccaskill on msnbc
fretting about the texas abortion law
which is a vigilante law she says
and then she she starts talking about
where she thinks this law will lead and
i'm not quite sure i follow her logic
but maybe you will listen to this
and i think this vigilantism is going to
catch on i'll tell you what's going to
happen next nicole these red states are
going to do vigilantism laws on
immigration
and they're going to empower citizens to
go out and round up people they think
look like foreigners
and that's what we're coming to in this
country and it is incredibly depressing
especially
as we're so near a religious holiday
that is all about loving other people
and accepting the least among us uh to
be part of the larger group uh okay a
couple things here
there are going to be laws in red states
empowering citizens to round up
foreigners yeah that's what
uh yeah just go round them up and that's
what the law is gonna say anyone who
looks like a foreigner just just round
them up ship them you know bring them
anywhere you want to bring them outside
of the country
well that's a thing that will actually
happen we can all see that
well yeah in her fever feverish brain uh
then yeah there might be a connection
there okay
but but also can i just say that what
she said at the end there like this is
the message of christmas what it's not
the
the message of christmas is accepting
people into the larger group or whatever
that's not the message of
of christmas
the message of christmas is that christ
the son of god has come to redeem
mankind
and save us from our sins that that's
the message of christmas
it's it's actually a religious holiday
with a very specific
meaning very specific religious
significance
significance to all mankind but it is a
it's a christian holiday
i know that i know they like to do this
you take any any uh christian holiday or
anything from the bible and um
anything at all from christian tradition
and
suddenly really this is all about
diversity and tolerance would you look
at that it's really all about uh the
things that we care about
that's all it is of course
all right
uh i want to play this quickly elon musk
was named time person of the year so we
had
the athlete of the year who was a
someone who quit
and now we have person of the year i
think elon musk can make a much better
case for himself for being personally
here for his actual
because in this case he's he's being
awarded the title for his actual
contributions
to society
uh not for quitting
but the left was very upset about that
and then they were even more upset
because uh he said this about vaccine
mandates
are you vaccinated yes yeah yeah yeah i
mean a very very pro vaccination i
believe uh it's the science is
unequivocal yeah i treat it to that
effect but by the same token i i am
against forcing people to be vaccinated
you know i think this is just not
something we should do in america i
think we should encourage people to be
vaccinated
strongly try to convince them to be
vaccinated right but not
force them to be vaccinated or for
example force them to get vaccinated or
get fired so elon musk is a is an
anti-vaxxer now um he's been he's been
inducted into the the club of
anti-vaxxers
uh along with a whole lot of other
people that never knew that they were
anti-vaxxers
that's something i've learned about
myself for the last year i never knew
that i was an anti-vaxxer i never was an
anti-vaccer i never tried to be an
anti-vaxxer
never had a problem in principle with
the concept of vaccines
you know and i never agree
there have always been there have been
there's there has been a certain group
of people i think a small group of
people
even before the coronavirus
you could accurately describe themselves
describe them as anti-vaccines they
would probably describe themselves that
way
in that they're opposed to all vaccines
and they're not going to give their kids
any vaccines it's a small group of
people
and it's still a small group of people
that that fall into that category
and that's their right
that's their own value system i don't
agree with it
but now we've expanded this and uh even
if you are in favor of the concept of
vaccines and you think it's great for
people to get vaccinated if they choose
to
if you simply believe that
there should be a choice there if you're
pro-choice when it comes to vaccines
and you think we shouldn't
destroy someone's livelihood
and take away their ability to feed
their kids because they don't get
vaccinated that makes you anti-vaxx so
welcome elon musk to the anti-vox crowd
all right next there's a sex of the city
sequel series called and just like that
and of course
the show is absurdly over the top woke
which is to be expected
i never watched the original sex in the
city but i i imagine that the original
for its time was also pretty woke
so there should be no surprise here but
there's one scene in particular that's
made its rounds online and uh it's it's
if you didn't know any better and you
didn't know anything about sex in the
city or anything else and you saw this
you would think that it was you would
almost think it was a parody you would
almost think it was like a babylon b
skit making fun of wokeness but it's not
i assure you so let's watch this hey
that's where the professor sits
sorry he just told me
someone's quick with the pronouns uh
it's fine
i am the professor
you're the professor yeah you're naya
wallace
yes why do you seem so surprised well
you're braids
a law professor can't have hair like
mine why is that oh no no i didn't i
didn't mean
because of the braids i was i was i was
just thrown because
the braids are are so different than the
hair in your photo on the columbia
website my comment had nothing
whatsoever to do with it being a black
hairstyle i i knew that you were black
when i signed up for this class that was
important to
me
you sign up for this class because i'm
black
well not just because you're black i
picked this class because
you're such a force in academia on top
of everything you do as a community
activist god i sound like such a brown
nose i mean um
please just forget that i ever said
anything about your hair
hair has
nothing whatsoever to do with
appropriateness or intelligence or
gravitas obviously i mean do i look like
someone who attaches any significance to
hair i i let mine go gray and i don't
care if it makes me look old not that
i'm ageist do i sound ageist
you really want me to answer that
question
uh again as far as i can tell again i've
never i haven't seen the show now i
would rather shoot myself than watch
this but as far as i can tell this is
this is not supposed to be a satire or
parody
or making fun of wokeness
so that's what you get there this is
real this is like one of those race
hoaxes
just like the one we talked about
yesterday of the of the doctor who
claimed that someone stopped a black
doctor in a suit and tie full suit and
tie at a hospital with a name tag that
says doctor on it claiming that someone
stopped him in the hallway and said
excuse me uh i assume that you're a
member of the custodial staff
please go go clean my toilets at once
that's what he claimed and um
i'll be clear very clearly a race hoax
from dr smilet this is one of those race
hoaxes acted out
this is because this is the kind of
conversation the kind of interaction
that especially elitists on the left um
they think that these sorts of things
happen out in the world
and that's why they're they're incapable
of coming up with a race hoax that's
believable
justice smellette a hollywood guy is
very privileged very you know wealthy
somehow managed to be wealthy and uh and
famous as an actor
he doesn't spend a lot of time around
normal people
now jesse smallett from his prison cell
if he's watching that
he's probably thinking himself well yeah
that's how this happens all the time
that a white person
would say to a black person well i
assume that you're not a professor
because of your hair
what i've because i've never seen a
professor with braids what
so this is uh
this the you know the people that that
write this they all exist in that that
same bubble
and that's what makes it so
unintentionally hilarious because this
would this just this is not life this is
not what happens
but for anyone who was disappointed or
upset as some people on social media
appear to be
that the new sex in the city is woke
i've seen a lot of complaints from
people so this new sex of the city
sequel is terrible
this is a this is a disappointment there
they are ruining the legacy of sex in
the city
what did you think was going to happen
just know this now
okay
this is
every franchise
every tv series
every film
it's it's all this now if there's any if
there's any franchise or series or movie
that came out prior to you know seven or
eight years ago that you liked
you should not want there to be any kind
of sequel or remake or anything
i saw on twitter someone someone put out
a kind of a question
for everybody and the question was
something like um
[Music]
you know what
which which series have been the most
ruined um
by going woke and the answer of course
is all of them this is what they all are
hollywood is not capable of producing
anything but this now
and so you have to understand it's it's
also
now that's a tv series so not eligible
for an academy award but
the academy has made this a rule now for
it's basically required now if you're
making a film and you want to
have a chance at winning an academy
award
which i'm not even sure why you'd care
about that anymore because the none of
the movie going public doesn't care
about it
that used to be one of the great one of
the values of winning an academy award
is that is that the public cares about
it and so if you can say that i'm an
academy award-winning actor more more
people are likely to go watch your next
movie that's not the case anymore nobody
cares but
the academy has put rules down
saying you have to have x number of
trans people an x number of this and
that so
this is every single series every movie
it will all be this
amazon has that new uh
lord of the rings prequel trilogy come
on they spent like a billion dollars on
it
a lot of people including many of
conservatives i followed social media
very excited about it because they're
big lord of the rings fans
well don't you on this is amazon
okay what do you think they're going to
do to it
and then you're going to sit down you're
going to watch it and be disappointed
because there's a there's a trans
non-binary disabled hobbit or something
of course
that's all of them
if it's coming from hollywood it is all
this they cannot do anything but this
all right finally this is from msn at a
junior hockey game in sioux falls south
dakota on saturday night five thousand
dollars in one dollar bills was dumped
onto a carpet in the middle of the ice
as 10 local teachers readied themselves
to shovel up as much as fit as they
could here's some of the footage here we
could play it for you and this was also
making the rounds in social media people
were very upset about this
um
there we go we see them
look at that crawling around on the
ground scooping up one dollar bills
[Music]
in front of the crowd
and the crowd isn't even cheering i
think the crowd is confused and
embarrassed by the whole
[Music]
spectacle yeah like maybe you could
justify this if they were 100 bills
somebody puts a bunch of one dollar
bills on the carpet and says do you want
to go
go go join that dog pile and try to grab
some i would say well no sir i have
dignity
then if i look over it's a hundred
dollar bills well okay i'll think about
it
um anyway back for msn it says when the
competition began the teachers all
wearing hockey helmets crawled into the
pile of cash frantically stuffing the
bills into their shirts as an arena of
spectators hollered and cheered i didn't
hear the cheering until every dollar was
snatched up
a clip of the went viral over the
weekend and had amassed more than 7.7
million on 7.7 million views on twitter
as of early monday critics said the
image of teachers on their hands and
knees scrambling for low denomination
bills was dehumanizing and even
dystopian especially as teachers are
paid relatively small salaries in south
dakota and nationwide
and people were very upset and uh and
the one the reason i'm bringing this up
is that the one theme that we we've
we've seen from the people responding to
the spectacle
is that education is underfunded and
this is supposedly
an example of of how education is
underfunded and we need more funding for
education i mean obviously it's
underfunded
if these teachers are forced to
crawl around on the ground or an ice
hockey rink
for one dollar bills
it must mean there's not enough funding
of education well i'm here to tell you
that is not the case at all
between state and local sources
we put between those two
we are funding education to the tune of
hundreds of billions of dollars
okay across the country
federal and state
cumulative we're talking hundreds and
hundreds of billions of dollars that go
into education
i mean anything that's getting hundreds
of billions of dollars it's hard to
argue that it's underfunded
but this is the government we're talking
about
so just because there's all this funding
of education
does that mean that every individual
class is appropriately funded or that
teachers all have the supplies that they
need
no it doesn't
so when i say that we're that we are
funding education quite enough in fact
we're funding it too much
much
there's far too much funding going into
education
am i denying
that there are teachers who don't have
enough
supplies in their classroom they have to
maybe go out of pocket sometimes
or reduce themselves to this they get
funding i'm not going to hang that
because the issue is the allocation of
those resources that's the problem
you're not going to solve that problem
by throwing more money at it
there's enough money to go around
it's just that it's misallocated
and that is that's almost always the
problem where the government is
concerned
if there's any
worthy program or cause or anything
that you consider to be worthy and it
doesn't seem to be getting enough
funding i can guarantee you the money is
there it's just not it's not getting
where it needs to go
it's getting dispersed somewhere else
along the line because this is what
bureaucracy does and education is this
is why the department of education
shouldn't exist because it's one big
giant bureaucracy and bureaucracies
exist for this person purpose really
to misallocate funds to waste money to
waste time
bureaucracies exist for their own sake
so everybody all the bureaucrats in the
department of education
they're all they're not there for
education or for your kid who's in
public school
or to make sure that a teacher has
enough supplies in the classroom they're
there for their own sake to justify
their own jobs to get paid themselves
so they're therefore that's why teachers
unions exist as well
so it's not under funding it's
misallocation big difference there you
probably feel like you're just burning
through money these days with how
expensive everything is whether you're
going grocery shopping or or you're at
the gas pump or anywhere else
that's why you should look for any
opportunity to save money monthly and
here's one thing that can do it
through refinancing your mortgage if you
own a home and haven't refinanced what
are you waiting for mortgage rates are
at historic lows once again which means
you can easily drop your rate and your
monthly payment all you've got to do is
call american financing america's home
for home loans take advantage of a free
mortgage review it's absolutely free
that means there's no pressure there's
no obligation there's no upfront fees
just a simple conversation with a salary
based mortgage consultant somebody's
going to listen to and guide you so
you're getting a custom loan that
achieves your goals from lower rates to
shorter terms even the ability to access
cash from your equity they're um they're
ready to find you the best deal possible
you can save up to a thousand dollars a
month may even skip two mortgage
payments creating greater upfront
savings and you can pre-qualify for free
by calling 866 569 47 that's 866
569-4711 or visit americanfinancing.net
let's get now to the comment section
matt hayden says my family is from
mayfield and my wife and kids were down
visiting for a family wedding while i
stayed in the cincinnati area to prep
for law school finals helpless is the
only word that describes how i felt
watching the weather reports while
trying to stay connected via phone
they were 200 yards away from the candle
factory that collapsed thank god the
storm missed them no legislation could
have prevented this nature does not
respond to our petty legislative goals
uh that sounds horrifying glad that your
family is safe
i mean i can't imagine that at all
um and that is
like as i said yesterday that that's the
the feeling of helplessness that you get
and what we experienced here in
nashville is like nothing compared to
that because
you know we were spared thankfully but
um
when the when the warning comes in
you go to a safe place you huddle down
and you know you could follow all the
recommendations they give you for how to
respond to a tornado warning and you
should follow those recommendations
but
if you survive it's there's going to be
an element of luck here that the tornado
didn't happen to fall right on top of
you
because if it goes right over where you
happen to be
um you're probably
doomed we prevent that can we stop that
through legislation i agree with you
matt i don't think so
johnny says matt i just realized how
perfect children's books are for you as
a writer you're lazy and writing more
than 30 pages is not possible
plus the text is really big and bubbly
so it's more like writing two pages keep
it up man
you may be angling to get banned from
the show but i'm not going to disagree
with your characterization there
it is a lot more fun writing children's
books i have to tell you a lot more fun
it's not that i no i can write real
books i've written two of them so far
it just takes me a long time
now ben shapiro can write a real book
that's like 70 000 words and he can
write it in two and a half weeks
okay it takes me more like two and a
half years to to do that
so i will not disagree with your
characterization you are correct but i
guess i'm going to ban you from the show
anyway
todd says hey matt i'm pretty sure west
side story is woke mostly because the
academy is forcing productions to fill
diversity check boxes or else they can't
win best picture uh yeah that's what i
mentioned before
that's that's part of it that's part of
it although even though we have to keep
in mind that the rules from the academy
are
ridiculous
um
but they're also it's also empty virtue
signaling as always so they they've been
written in such a way that they can be
easily circumvented
that's how they're written
so there's no still no excuse for all
this woke stuff even if you are a
filmmaker desperate to win an academy
award anna says so my thoughts on the
cancellation today um why would you be
offended somebody thought you were a
janitor it's a good job honest pay
aren't your assumptions about this
interaction offensive to janitors why do
you assume the person is being racist
instead of just not particularly
observant
that's a good point i thought about that
afterwards i wish i had mentioned it but
there's also an elitism here
there's this basic assumption putting
everything else aside about how the
story is
almost certainly fabricated
but the underlying assumption is that
it's
insulting to be considered a janitor
because janitors are inferior to doctors
so while trying to prove the racism of
this fictional person he's only proving
that he is
you know an elitist himself
john says 100 kids die in bicycle
accidents in a year
well i haven't checked the statistics
myself but
um
if that's true that's interesting
because that's about the number that was
cited by
tony fauci yesterday for the number of
kids i think between 5 and 11
who've died from coronavirus
in in about two years
and yet
and i'm sure this is why you brought
this up 100 kids die in bicycle
accidents it's a terrible tragedy
um
but yet parents will still let their
children ride bikes
you know i know that i will
i love my kid of course you make sure
they're wearing a helmet but you still
let them ride the bike
even though there's a chance e with the
with the helmet still there's a chance
of some horrific injury
but you let them do that even even for
the for the sake of
of riding a bike i mean you could take
bikes
you could take bicycles away from kids
and it would be a shame to do that but
they could still otherwise live a mostly
normal life
right you're not interfering with your
child's life in any serious way by
taking the bicycle away
yet simply for the sake of being able to
ride a bike and have a fun time riding a
bike you're willing to take that risk
yet at the same time
when there's an even lower risk of your
kid contracting coveted dying from it
while walking around outside or walking
through a supermarket you're still gonna
you're enforcing aware mask
which is a much greater imposition on
him than taking a bike away
um
greg says hey matt we just got johnny
the walrus yesterday and it's now my
son's favorite book to read at night
that would be more significant if i
hadn't taken away all other books as
they are all worthless in comparison
well thank you greg
finally someone is responding the right
way to my book johnny the walrus which
by the way is on sale right now at
johnnywalrus.com
um
and cassandra says do you wear makeup
and use product in your hair while on
the road cassandra i've told you i don't
have times i've told you we don't talk
about this it's not a subject we talk
about we're not going to talk about it
i don't talk about the fact that when
i'm on the road my producer sean who's
very much a man has to be the one
applying to makeup i'm also going to
talk about the fact that just a few
minutes ago when we were doing that and
the makeup was being applied um and i
had this clip from sex in the city and
so we were talking about sex in the city
while the makeup was being applied
in this hotel room we're not going to
discuss that topic
so you're banned from the show
the daily wire is leading the charge
against the bind administration's
tyrannical vaccine mandates not only
were we the first in the nation to sue
the buy administration for their
unconscious unconstitutional mandate but
we're getting closer to a million
signatures on our do not comply petition
every single day why because people are
realizing that if we don't actively
fight for our freedom the government
will take it uh we have a goal of
reaching one million signatures which
would provide a major boost to our legal
challenge and uh we're you know almost
there we have over 850 000 signatures so
far but we need your help to cross the
finish line so please if you have not
done yet sign the petition at
dailywire.com do not comply and then
share our petition with all of your
friends and family let's send the
message so loud that the buy
administration will be forced to hear it
and also for all of you sweet babies out
there who have dreamed of joining the
daily wire team now's your chance we
currently have several open positions
that we are actively working to fill the
details of which can be found at
dailywire.com careers this week we're
highlighting the platform manager
opening with our marketing department
there is a mid-level marketing manager
role that calls for someone who is
highly detail-oriented extremely
analytical numbers oriented and
constantly looking for ways to optimize
let's get a sweet baby in management
that should be our goal the um this is
kind of an infiltration of the sweet
baby gang
a takeover an insurrection if you want
to call it that of the daily wire itself
from the inside the platform manager
will be responsible for creating leading
strategies to grow the daily wire and
our talents brand awareness as well as
maintaining all operations for the
platform this is an in-office position
in nashville tennessee if you or someone
you know could be the perfect fit for
this opportunity or any of our open
positions we're accepting applications
through our career pages at
dailywire.com
careers
now let's get to our daily cancellation
[Music]
today we're cancelling everybody who has
anything to do with this story out of
newburgh united methodist church in
indiana um religionnews.com reports
when pastor craig duke appeared in drag
on the hbo reality show we're here he
knew that some members of his united
methodist congregation would appreciate
the episode and that others wouldn't
even watch it
he also knew some members of his
congregation support the full inclusion
of lgbtq christians in the church and
others don't and that would make his
performance on the show a challenging
experience but he didn't think it would
cost him his job
now before we go on
reflect on the fact that a pastor
appeared in drag on a drag reality show
and based on his many years of
experience in the church had assumed
that it wouldn't cost him his job
so before we analyze pastor craig's
decision making what does that say about
the church that he felt comfortable
doing this and thought it would be okay
what does it say about the state of
christianity in the west
but we'll continue it says the emails
from congregants began not long after
duke's episode of we're here aired on
november 8th uh the pastor said the show
follows renowned drag artists eureka
o'hara
shangela and bob the drag queen as they
travel to small cities and towns across
the united states transforming locals
into drag queens
duke accepted an invitation to appear in
an episode filmed in the evansville area
because he said he wanted to better
empathize with lgbtq people in his
community and to express support for his
daughter who recently came out as
pansexual
another quick pause here um
the way to support your pansexual
daughter is to tell her that pansexual
isn't a thing okay it's made up
you might as well say that your daughter
came out as a centaur or as a tooth
fairy
because pansexual means someone who is
uh quote gender blind that's how they
would describe themselves
gender blind in their sexual attraction
meaning that a person's sex does not
factor into whether the pansexual finds
them sexually attractive or not but you
see the problem here
you can't have sexual attraction apart
from sex
so that makes no sense
there are people who experience sexual
attraction to both sexes those are
called bisexuals
which is why we don't need this other
term
uh pansexual
except the pansexual claims to be
attracted to no sex claiming that sex is
irrelevant but again that can't be true
it's like saying that you're hungry and
you want pancakes but you don't desire
the pancakes because they're food you're
food blind
it just makes no sense okay anyway
continuing it says some of the messages
the pastor received were positive enough
were so negative that at the assistance
of newburgh's staff parish relations
committee duke said he requested a new
assignment from bishop julius c trimble
of the indiana conference of united
methodist church it's not unusual for
united methodist bishops to reassign
pastors regularly to different churches
or to other leadership positions those
appointments generally take effect in
july in the meantime
duke planned to lead a six-week bible
study about sexuality at the church
something he hoped would create dialogue
within the congregation
but another negative bullying attacking
email from a church person arrived
november 14th that flipped the tide for
the pastor he said
it just got to the point where the
conflict the anger grew too much and so
for my mental health for my mental
health i started to back away and i told
my district superintendent the conflict
was so much it was at such a level from
some that i was unable to be an
effective leader
okay so in the end
the the drag queen pastor
wasn't even fired
he chose to leave for his own sake for
his own mental health is why he left
and i i don't doubt that he's mentally
unhealthy i don't doubt that but that
was the case long before this clearly
by the way if you're wondering um
if we're going to play a clip of of the
of the drag queen store with the drag
pastor well you're in luck because here
it is
reverend
craig duke
the only reverend that i would ever want
to preach at me in a church i think we
need to find a way to support equip and
empower we do that not with our
condemnation but with our love so we
ended up doing this thing with the
performances with craig where he started
in this fabulous choir robe preacher
look where he was preaching to his
congregation about love and then it tore
away into kesha's we are who we are
it was so good
we fully had to do a lift with craig and
he was so paranoid that we weren't gonna
be able to lift him up but mama we
picked her up like the only dainty
flower also
craig knew every single word to his song
because he's dope and super fire and he
hangs jesus on his necklace as us
you know i think that there was such a
campy element that craig thought he had
to bring to it and what i did is i
pushed craig to realize that drag's not
a joke
you know gender expression fluidity and
art it's never a joke for people that
need it so reverend duke really wanted
to do this drag number to show the world
like i'm willing to walk in the shoes of
the queer people that i love that i
enjoy and mama he opened up he performed
and sass and fresh he was a hard-working
little diva
okay
drag is not a joke he says
so let's sure let's go back and look at
this screenshot um just a quick quick
look at this quick freeze frame
he says that this is not a joke there we
go
yeah not a joke he says
you've got a pastor dressed like dolly
parton's meth addicted cousin
dancing next to ursula from the little
mermaid
but this is not a joke
and he's right you know it's it's not a
comedy really it's it's a horror show
it's a joke in the same way that the end
of the movie psycho is a joke
but remember remember something else
that the drag queen said he said that uh
that pastor duke
is the only pastor he'd want preaching
to him or at him as he put it if he ever
went to church which of course he
doesn't
but he's the only one you know that's
that's the kind of pastor i would want
now that's not a good thing okay if
you're a pastor
that's not the kind of thing you want to
hear about yourself
if somebody who hates your faith and
hates christian values
and opposes everything that you're
supposed to stand for says that you're
the only pastor he'd want preaching to
him that means you're not doing your job
it means that you're tickling ears right
you're whispering sweet nothings
you're telling the sinner what he wants
to hear or at least you're not telling
him what he doesn't want to hear
you're making him um
comfortable in his sin in his pride
that's really what what all that is
about i mean
what you saw there the drag show
it's really it's a celebration of vanity
and pride
and and other things as well but mostly
vanity and pride
what you're not doing and what you
should be doing as a pastor is spurring
him to confront and go to war against
precisely those parts of himself that he
wants you to affirm
that's that's not what pastoring is
supposed to be about it's not supposed
to be about affirming people in their
sin or making them feel comfortable
in their lifestyle choices
you're supposed to be
be encouraging causing
um propelling people to confront
those parts of their life
especially those parts of their life
that are keeping them away from from
virtue
and holiness
now i mean obviously if a pastor is
performing in drag on hbo he's gone
astray so maybe maybe it's there's no
point in pointing this out it's rather
obvious but it is instructive in
revealing that the head drag honcho
said what he said
this is the kind of pastor i want this
is the pastor i like
because you often hear certain so-called
religious leaders praised
by people who hate the religion that
he's supposed to be leading
and this is why this is where it goes
and that's why pastor craig duke
is canceled
and his church is canceled and obviously
that drag queen is also canceled they're
all canceled
and we'll leave it there for today
thanks for watching thanks for listening
have a great day godspeed
[Music]
the matt walsh show is produced by sean
hampton executive producer jeremy boring
our supervising producer is mathis
glover our technical director is austin
stevens production manager pablo vadosky
the show is edited by ali hinkle our
audio is mixed by mike coromina hair
makeup is done by cherokee heart and our
production coordinator is mckenna waters
the matte wall show is a daily wire
production copyright dailywire 2021.
the cdc releases omicron case numbers
joe biden continues to tumble in poles
and the pc police add another couple
letters to the diversity inclusion
and equity initialism check it out on
the michael knowles show